[Music]
camp was really a fantastic experience
it seemed like something that was
actually gonna challenge me and
something that was I was gonna like it
was my type of thing basically myself
there a law really interesting students
here and they're all really passionate
about programming and learning about
pure science what I really enjoyed was
meeting a lot of people that had the
same kind of enthusiasm that I had for
developing really cool projects using
Mathematica and well from ham you were
living and breathing from language and
computation and mathematics you really
feel as a high school student I get in
like you're at the frontier or something
new and exciting with more from I was
able to take my own interests and create
my own project based on what I wanted to
do and what I was interested in then I
was given the help to make that possible
there isn't the pressure of grades and
there isn't the pressure of testing but
you're internally motivated to do well
and that's really nice I got to talk
with Stephen Wolfram and a lot of
different instructors on my project so
that also helped me a lot in figuring
out how I can learn from this product
[Music]
Suman was pretty involved in camp it was
nice being able to talk one-on-one with
him about our projects or just maybe
like about us I also really liked having
those guest lectures on different topics
those allowed me to get a bigger
perspective on what those fields are
like like that's stuff that you can take
back and bring in throughout your life I
was looking for a challenge I didn't
know how I would find it I learned what
shape it would appear but I definitely
found it here
you